Це український танк ще радянської
розробки т-64 солдати ЗСУ жортома
запитують німецькі журналістів а чи не
привезли вони сучасні леопарди радянські
танки - це все що вони мають
немає так сказать щоб ми можемо там
вибирати і Що є то є
цей танковий батальйон веде бої під
бахмутом де ЗСУ намагаються прорвати
російські позиції на південних та
північних околицях українці там повільно
просуваються вперед
більш проблема в тому що вони очікували
що ми підемо зараз там в Контрнаступ В
цьому плані і Ну наприклад прямо тут на
цьому напрямку те що тут тріхи
рельєф там
поганий для того щоб нам штурмувати бо в
них там трошки висоти краще
як тільки танкісти повертаються завдання
механіки розпочинають технічне
обслуговування бойової машини цьому
підрозділу пощастило більше за інших
Вони спочатку війни втратили лише
половину танків цей судячи з його броні
пережив уже багато
тут було все
повивернуто
замінили і до бою
броня старатись боєздатних
ці танки радянських часів значно легші
за свої західній аналоги Це робить їх
більше маневреними але знижує
захищеність екіпажу ключовим елементом
радянської розробки є автоматична
система заряджання це означає що танк
може швидко перезаряджатися але це таїть
у собі небезпеку у разі детонації
боєзаряду гине весь екіпаж це стало
проблемою для росіян адже вони воюють на
таких самих танках ЗСУ за допомогою
західних протитанкових комплексів зуміли
знищити чимало бронемах машин з
екіпажами всередині
у Джавелін Time Love це ну страшна річ
ось
Ну я не знаю Це ж треба ще попасти це
треба щоб була ця зброя
в них є і немає
українці досі цінують т-64 танк був
розроблений у 60-х роках у Харкові
загалом він ще підходить до ведення бою
танковий парк дістався Україні після
розвалу Радянського Союзу і хоча на
українській позиції пробули західні
танки зокрема леопарди для багатьох
підрозділів т-64 які раніше залишаються
основною бойовою машиною
Але в нього є і суттєві проблеми одна з
найбільших швидкий перегрів двигуна
влітку навіть коротка подорож може бути
непростою
[музика]
в умовах нестачі леопардів надія заєсу
на трофейні радянський танки
росіяни переважно використовують більш
сучасні моделі порівняно з 164 а саме
т-72
Мені більш подобається трофе
йні вона бистріша вона новіша
не так часто поломки
єздем роботи Ну то есть бувало що
виїжджали там по три конвеєра працювали
ось
виїхали розрядились противника вернулися
загрузили поехали ще раз
на цих кадрах замаскований Трофей ЗСУ
на броні навіть видно букву Z
проте воюють цей танк вже за Україну
перша ж партія американських танків
Абрамс має прибути в Україну лише на
початку Цієї осені у відділі закупівель
армії США кажуть що це не просто танки а
повний пакет який йде разом з ними тобто
і боєприпаси і запчастини і паливне
обладнання і ремонтні засоби втім за
даними видання politico перша партія
налічуватиме лише від 6 до 8 танків
загалом же США планують відправити в
Україну 31 танк що відповідає
українському танковому батальйону
в США також працюють з європейськими
союзниками над створенням потужностей
для ремонту танків Абрамс та іншої
важкої бронетехніки переданої Україні
Німеччина ще навесні передала 18
сучасних бойових танків леопард-2 поляки
надали 14 із пенсії шведи по 10 а також
інші союзники загалом щонайменше 85
машин точно число з міркувань безпеки
тримається в секреті Крім того в Україні
вже є і старіші моделі німецьких танків
леопард 1 загалом Берлін схвалив експорт
178 цих машин першою станковою коаліції
союзників погодилась надати ЗСУ основні
бойові танки західного зразка
Великобританія 14 одиниць челенджер-2
вже в Україні і готові до бою